hi and welcome to the Google+ platform
podcast I'm Francis campoy a developer
advocate for the web platform and I'm
here with my colleague mark hi I'm mark
Mendel I'm also a developer advocate of
Google cloud platform it's great to be
here today yeah great to be with you
here today
so yeah what is this that we're doing
today what is the Google cloud platform
podcast apparently we're doing a podcast
talking about Google cloud platform
which i think is pretty awesome I'm
really excited about this project
yeah I made sure I'm really excited just
to give an idea about what people should
expect these episodes let's talk a
little bit before we start with any
content that we're gonna be covering
today yeah what is the normal
architecture the normal layout oh yeah
yeah so all right so first we want to
start with what we're calling the cool
thing of the week cool it's gonna be
great so basically any sort of really
interesting project may be open source
maybe a new launch maybe a tip or trick
something that that we think is going to
be saving people time when they work on
Google cloud platform we want to share
it with the audience and we want this to
be really like sort of participatory
yeah if you've got something out there
you know we're happy to fill in the
details but if you're like man check out
this project it's also a more I did this
great thing and it saved me a heap of
time please send it through to us we
really want to hear about it
yeah and by the way if you want to if
you really get in contact with us to
share any of those cool things of the
week we have many ways of contacting us
the most important one is our webpage
yep she's TCP podcast comm yep then I
think we also have an email hello at GCP
podcast.com that's easy yeah and then we
are also on Twitter GCB podcast on
reddit we have the subreddit GCP podcast
yep and then you can also find us on
google google plus what is searching JCP
podcast yeah if you search the Google
cloud platform podcast I prefer to say
kisi big much easier to say so yeah that
we're gonna have that part that at the
beginning of the
gonna be very participative yeah we
waiting for it for your proposals and
then at the end of the episode we will
finish with something quite similar but
rather than saying something that is
cool it's gonna be the question of the
week yeah
really looking forward to this as well
really interested to see what questions
people are gonna send us through I think
it's gonna be a great resource and it's
always fun you know in events we get
great questions so we'd love to share
the answers that we can find when people
think that's gonna be lots of fun
yeah I'm actually very excited about
this part just because most of the
questions that we will get hopefully we
will we will not know the answer
directly I think everybody down now
we're gonna have to find out with other
Google engineers but managers and so on
and after that we're gonna learn a lot
so break set about that yeah so what's
coming between the question of the week
and the cool thing of the week as well
yeah that's that's the little section we
call the main content so we're gonna be
covering we're gonna be doing many
different things the idea is that we're
gonna have like deep dives on some
specific topic like we're gonna be
talking a doorknob like what is
datastore or sequel versus my sequel a
sequel versus no sequel things like that
but also we want to cover all the topics
so we're gonna be interviewing all the
product managers engineers people that
are cool and interesting yeah I think
also customer projects yeah there's
people out there using Google cloud
platform and you'd love to come on the
podcast
oh yeah Yap to us we totally want to
speak to you be great to have you on it
yeah and find out you know what well
people out there in the wild are doing I
mean that's that's really the
interesting stuff - cool yeah so
basically we're pretty open we're gonna
be talking about things that we think
are cool yeah that's pretty much it
so okay so what are we gonna be talking
about today then
okay so cool thing of the week I think
it's pretty straightforward we have a
podcast yeah that's pretty cool that's
pretty cool indeed and so yeah and what
about the main content so we built the
podcast for Google cloud platform
strangely enough on Google cloud
platform that's right so when we have a
chat about what we did to build that
and sort of let people know how they
could even build their own podcasts on
top of Google I don't think they want to
do
that's not like a good idea and actually
just to give a little bit of context
about how this India came up to be so
some months ago I was chatting with mark
about the idea of having a podcast and
we basically planned everything out we
decided everything that had to be done
and then I went on a month of traveling
a mark implemented office so so
basically rather than us explaining how
we did it it's gonna be more like me
asking mark and I hope I will be
learning some stuff from okay okay
sounds great cool so first what what is
a podcast like what are the pieces you
know podcast
okay so podcast well obviously if you're
listening this you have some some
familiar with podcasts and it's a audio
recording where we talk about stuff when
we do it on a regular basis this is
planning on being weekly which is going
to be great so to actually have a
podcast we need audio files generally
mp3 files when you store them somewhere
we need some sort of website that shows
what we're talking about with some
content very much like a blog still
notes and all that other fun stuff and
the other big piece actually got to step
back a bit we'll need some analytics
that's really important for us where the
Google Data is very important so we need
to be able to see who's doing what on
the website and downloads things like
that and finally we need an RSS feed
it's really important for podcasting
it's an XML feed that basically says
here are episodes so people can
subscribe to it you know what episodes
are coming up now and then you know when
you episodes come out which is be nice
so basically we have we have to post
some information get both files and yes
ml then we have to may have some way of
distributing it yep and then we want to
measure how successful we are yes that's
it go okay so so how do we store that
data where is that data stored how do we
serve well on that we do magic stuff
okay so the mp3 files themselves the
easy answer for that was Google Cloud
storage so that's our platform for
storing binary files go it's really cool
and it's very easy to use you can get a
bucket
you upload a file generally I do it
through the web interface yeah really
simple yeah you can literally drag and
drop yeah yes pretty nice and Google
Cloud Storage has education or education
because I've never had an accent and so
depending on where you are in the world
and make sure the files are redundant
least or close to you so you have really
latency so it's really awesome and so
it's yeah very simple we just feels like
ok that's that's quite clearly where
those go and it makes life very very
simple yeah that's actually something
that for a lot of people is really
important the fact that when you put
something on Google Cloud Storage it
might feel like you're storing it in a
disk yeah that's it but actually you're
not you're storing it everywhere in the
world so depending on where people are
accessing it it's gonna be edged - yeah
anywhere so that means that if super few
downloads yeah if you're if you're
listening to be pop these podcasts from
Australia or from Japan or from
Barcelona
you will get the same the same
experience so very fast experience up it
starts downloading yeah very very super
super important but then there's also
the fact that we don't want people to
listen to the next episodes of the
podcast so we can also upload stuff and
then keep it private for a little bit
I'll share with what we call ackles or
access control lists yeah that's right
yeah so basically that way we can say ok
the the the episode is ready we're gonna
share it only with people that we wanted
to the reviews and so on so so H it's
pretty powerful very easy to use but
very powerful yeah yeah and for a
podcaster it's very easy for Cisco this
is all public read go forth be happy and
very very simple cool
cool so ok so now we have those files
yeah that that's that's just the audio
yeah what about the rest what about all
the content the show notes ok so what we
did for that was a very interesting
things I think so we went with a static
site generator for the website project
called Hugo
we did that for a number of reasons
mainly because it's written and go and
franceska likes go a lot so it is
actually a really nice static site
generator so we built the website with
that and we
extend it to do all this stuff for
podcasting and it worked really really
well so once we had all the study files
that Hugo generates yeah we needed
somewhere herself so that makes sense we
and we actually had a few options with
that we ended up actually going with
hosting stuff hosting our static files
on App Engine itself which is a little
bit maybe controversial which is
interesting but we didn't think a few
good reasons one of which is App Engine
gives us really easy access to HTTP
support yeah so you can bundle it up
stick it on App Engine put it up in the
cloud magic cloud it still has an edge
caching much like Google Cloud Storage
that's right which is really nice we can
also upload multiple versions that can
be served at the same time on different
like URLs yeah that's something that I
really like the fact that you can do no
better testing I forgot hey you be
testing AV testing that's it so yeah you
can do a B testing and the answer is
that what sisters version is more
performant things like that yeah and
it's great to like I can make a podcast
episode put it up on a different URL
send it to friends desk and say hey does
this look right to you he's like yep
sweet yeah I hit a button in the
dashboard it switches it out with no
downtime which is really nice too yeah
that's really nice yeah I mean other
reason we went with App Engine is
because we can we can also do dynamic
content so maybe I should actually step
back a little bit and talk a little bit
about what App Engine is for those
people who don't know that sounds like
that very go to the end there okay so
App Engine is one of our always our
primary platform as a service offerings
so what that really means is we kind of
say hey you need to write your code this
way and we're going to kind of dictate
it to you and as long as you're happy to
do that then that means we can do stuff
like really fast scaling we can provide
you with a whole bunch of services
out-of-the-box deployment is really easy
because we're able to sort of adjust
based on those constraints we put upon
you and yeah as long as that fits with
you it's pretty cool so I mean there's a
lot of customers we have that use App
Engine and like the model because we can
they can just be like oh I don't really
care how much traffic I get because that
engine is going to handle it for me oh
that's awesome
so it's pretty cool I mean it supports
go it supports PHP Java and Python
yeah out of the box and so there are
some pretty decent languages that have
some pretty pretty decent like
penetration into there yeah that's the
thing that I really like about App
Engine is that basically what you do is
you just give us your code and there's
some restrictions of what kind of code
you can run but you basically just give
us your code and if it matches our
restrictions then we'll just run it for
you yeah whatever happens and the
restrictions are pretty like reasonable
I mean it's for web stuff right so it
says you know no requests over 60
seconds well you probably shouldn't be
doing that yeah and there's things like
you cannot run C+ blasting yeah that but
if you want to do that we have we have
others yeah with other business to run
it and yeah there's some of the
customers that run this it's actually
pretty impressive because do things like
oh yeah it's something that's going to
scale but can I actually trust it
yeah there's rocío that you said this
can Academy that uses it yeah there's
snapchat snapchat is huge yeah it's it's
huge and it supports like it just
running on App Engine we do something
like ten times the traffic of Wikipedia
looking at some slides we've had yeah on
a penny in general yeah yeah it's pretty
impressive quite a decent amount of
traffic
yeah and for our needs here for a
podcast I mean we fit we fit the mold
really well learn it um so we can serve
an aesthetic site the static content
through it no problem which is great but
yeah we've also got some go code that
we're using to do our analytics cool
which is the other side of things so
what we do is we basically have just a
very simple redirect in our code to say
where we're downloading a podcast from
okay and what that does is on that
redirects the HTTP request comes in and
we do a 503 it redirects to it redirects
to the storage that storage yeah oh my
god brain just fell over yeah so it
sends up a request to Google Analytics
using a little girl library we have
basically saying hey here's an event of
a podcast download and he likes podcast
so we're able to leverage Google Cloud
Google Analytics and used all its
tooling and basically be able to still
use all the code on App Engine at the
same time so we can have dynamic code
running we can have static content at
the same time deployments really easy
and yeah yeah it's pretty sweet
it's actually other than us
that's right nice so for the people are
curious about it
what's the library that you're using for
go-go Oval Analytics I will be in the
show notes that's I think the package
name is actually GA when it actually
gets used it's actually it's a really
nice library it uses Google Analytics
measurement API and I you can send any
data I'm sure we'll get more
sophisticated with it yeah that's right
yeah it's pretty nice cool okay so now
that we've seen how to store our data
files like audio files and everything
else will be HTML CSS images and so on
we've seen how we manage how we measure
our success but how do we cause that
success how do how do we know how we
make people realize that there's a new
episode out there so the big thing here
is what's called like an RSS feed I
think it stands for Really Simple
Syndication and there's a few other
versions good it's essentially an XML
feed if anyone's been involved with
blogging they've probably seen this in
one way or another it's an XML format
that says hey I just wrote a new blog
post or a new episode of something so
when podcasting came around it's sort of
got extended a little bit so not only is
it like hey I just put out a blog post
it's like hey I've got out a blog post
and it's got this audio attached to it
and there's some extensions for iTunes
and some extensions for other things
like that to be able to put some
metadata around that audio file but it
becomes a really simple way of letting
everyone don't be subscribing hey
there's a new podcast we listen to it
it's kind of cool come on down that's
nice and so once we have that RSS feed
that we are publishing how will people
find it like they can go to GCP podcast
com sure yeah and there's a there's a
link directly there so you could you
could just go to the GCP podcast your
podcast if you've got a podcast app or
anything like that you can just point
the XML feed quite easily
it'll be on iTunes we'll probably get on
a stitcher at some point so nice
I'm sure if yeah it should be pretty
easy to get onboard
cool so the last part is okay sure so
now we have a static compton static site
yeah why did people want to comment on
it okay so alright what we decided to do
was basically use
communities so as we said before if
people want to contact us they can do
what I'm ready and they can do it on
Google+ so we're gonna put a post there
for every episode and just say hey if
you want to add comments please come
talk to us here yeah it makes life
really simple when we can take advantage
of those communities so I think that's
gonna okay I would quite well
I'm actually a brick sorry it's official
about ready yeah it's a very active
community and hopefully we're gonna get
nice conversations I haven't
participated in that much you read it I
already honest no but yeah I'm always
open to new things so that's not like it
I think it's gonna be fun
okay cool cool so I think that with that
we cannot finish how to run a focus on
the cloud yeah I think it's cool that
that was pretty easy that was yeah
thought so we said that we had the
question the the cool thing of the week
yep
then the main content so now we're going
for the third part which is a question
of the week do you happen to have one I
happen to have a question of the week I
was at an event a little while ago it
was a sports themed event and so this
question came up where we were talking
about we had a potential customer asked
me about whether we were HIPAA compliant
what is that well I'm not gonna try and
explain it to the degree of being a
lawyer but essentially if you're doing
health type things then you might need
this sort of governmental compliance to
be able to be like yes I could run
legally this case really really good
agent hey busted for health somehow yeah
as h IP double-a compliant and the nice
answer to that question is actually yes
we are HIPAA compliant cool if you're
interested in HIPAA compliance or any
other compliance we actually have a page
under group was it cloud.google.com
slash security slash compliance where we
talk about all that compliance needs we
do business a business associate
agreements all that sort of fun stuff as
well so generally speaking if you need
that sort of compliance you didn't
really know you need that sort of
compliance yeah if you do need that sort
of compliance to you don't know you'll
find out pretty quickly but yeah I mean
it was thankfully was real easy question
to answer when when we got us so yeah I
mean and then also in that in a URL you
can check our security
as well as a lot of actually really yeah
there's a lot of really interesting
information out there
great so you said that the question of
the week from the for this week came
from an event yep
what else are you gonna be doing
regarding two events what are you doing
next I've got a few things on my plate
the thing probably looked in the most
I'll mention is I will be at closure
conch and November I do like my
functional programming so I'm really
excited about that I'll be talking about
repping closure developer tools in
containers where are you gonna be in the
next little while gonna be many many
places actually yeah in November I'm
gonna go to our dev
nobody sure I pronounce it correctly the
weird cause no legs okay Swedish oh so
sure yeah it's in Malmo it's gonna be a
very nice conference I'm gonna be
talking about go and go on the cloud and
then I'm going to go to dot go which is
Paris course okay go conference again
yeah it's gonna be really fun I don't
know what I'm gonna be talking about but
I think it's gonna be quite fun
functional programming Ingo we should
talk about that yeah it's gonna be scary
and then we're gonna have a lot of
people from from our team from Google
platform advocacy team that works in
Antwerp Belgium that should be lots of
fun it's a shame I'm missing that
actually we're gonna be running couple
workshops we're happy there so if you're
gonna be somewhere around there feel
free to come say hi yeah brilliant okay
well that sounds great well if you
aren't gonna be those events please feel
free to send us an email reach out to us
on Twitter reach out to us on reddit
we'd love to talk to you community
interaction is awesome you're super
looking forward to that side of
everything let's remind people where we
can reach us okay so for the web page is
GCP podcast blog um lovely for the email
is hello GCB podcast calm for the door
handle is Jesus for there's just ECP
podcast oh yeah I got to
for the reddit so for the subreddit is
GCP podcast yeah and then you can find
us on Google+ searching for Google cloud
platform podcast wonderful okay well I
think that probably wraps us up there
right well thank you very much for
joining me Francis I look forward to
doing many of these with you sir yeah
thank you and see you next week see you
next week